MICHALE FEE: OK, good
morning, everyone.
OK, so today we are
going to continue
the process of building
our equivalent circuit
model of a neuron.
This model was actually
developed in the late '40s
and early '50s by Alan
Hodgkin and Andrew
Huxley, who started working on
the problem of understanding
how neurons make
action potentials.
And so they studied
the squid giant axon,
which is actually a
very cool preparation,
because that axon is actually
about a millimeter across,
and so you can stick
wires inside of it.
And they did a bunch of
very cool experiments
to figure out how these
different ionic conductances
and how these different
components of the circuit
work together to make
an action potential.
So that's what we're
going to continue doing,
we're going to
essentially continue
describing and motivating
the different components
of this circuit.
So today, we're going to
get through the process
of introducing a
voltage-measuring device,
a current source, a
capacitor, a conductance,
and we're going to start
introducing a battery, OK?
OK.
So here's what we want
to accomplish today.
So we want to understand how
kind of at the simplest level
how neurons respond
to injected currents,
we want to understand
how membrane
capacitance and membrane
resistance allows neurons
to integrate their
inputs over time,
and to filter their inputs or
smooth their inputs over time--
and that particular model is
called a resistor capacitor
model or an RC
model of a neuron.
We're going to go through how
to derive the differential
equations that describe that
model-- it's actually quite
simple, but some
of you may not have
been through that before,
so I want to go through it
step by step so we
can really understand
where that comes from.
And we're going to learn to
basically look at a current--
a pattern of current
injection, and we
should be able to
intuitively see
how the voltage of
that neuron responds.
And we're going to
start working on where
the batteries of a neuron
actually come from, OK?
OK.
So-- all right.
So we're going to basically
talk about the following sort
of thought experiment, OK?
The following conceptual idea.
We're going to take
a neuron and we're
going to put it in a
bath of sailing, OK?
A saltwater solution that
represents the extracellular
solution that neurons--
extracellular
solution in the brain.
And we're going to put an
electrode into that neuron
so that we can inject
current, and we're
going to put another
electrode into the neuron
so that we can
measure the voltage,
and we're going to study
how this neuron responds--
how the voltage of the neuron
responds to current injections,
OK?
Now why is it that we
want to actually do that?
Why is that an interesting or
important experiment to do?
Anybody have any
idea why we would
want to actually measure
voltage and current
for a neuron in the brain?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Be able to use the
mathematical model [INAUDIBLE]
provided for us?
MICHALE FEE: OK, but
it's more than just
so that we can describe
it mathematically, right?
It's because these things--
something about
voltage and current
are actually relevant to
how a neuron functions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Like the
resistance inside?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So that's an important
quantity, but we're
looking for something
more fundamental,
like why is it
actually important
that we understand how voltage
changes when a neuron has
current injected into it?
Habiba?
AUDIENCE: Equals [INAUDIBLE]
different like ion channels,
a different set of
voltages [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
So ion channels are
sensitive to voltage,
and the way they function
depends very critically
on voltage.
So many-- if not
most-- ion channels
are voltage sensitive and are
controlled by voltage, OK?
And that's exactly why.
So nearly every aspect of
what neurons do in the brain
as you're walking around looking
at things and doing things
is controlled by
voltage, and that
goes through the voltage
sensitivity of buying channels,
OK?
But what is it that changes
the voltage in a neuron?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The action potential.
MICHALE FEE: That's
on the output side.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it
ion concentration?
MICHALE FEE: Good.
That's correct.
I'm looking for something
a little bit different.
Habiba?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
pumps or [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, those
are all good answers.
Not quite what I'm looking for.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
So the answer is that
the voltage of a neuron
changes because--
the reason current is important
is because the reason voltage
changes in a neuron is because
other cells are injecting
current into our neuron.
Sensory inputs are injecting
current into our neuron, OK?
Everything that a neuron
receives, all the information
that a neuron receives from
other neurons in the network
and from the outside world
comes from currents being
injected into that neuron, OK?
And so it's really
important that we understand
how the neuron transforms that
current input from other cells
and from the sensory periphery
into voltage changes that
then change the behavior
of ion channels.
Is that clear?
That link of current
inputs to voltage output
is really crucial,
and that's why we're
doing this experiment, OK?
OK, and that's this
point right here.
OK, so one of the
first things we're
going to see when we go
through this analysis
is that neurons can
perform analog integration.
They can perform numerical
integration over time, OK?
That's pretty cool.
Voltage is that integral over
time of the injected current.
To first order.
It's the simplest
behavior of a neuron.
So if you measure the
voltage of a neuron
and you turn on current and
you turn the current on,
the voltage of a
neuron will ramp up,
integrating that
input over time, OK?
Pretty cool.
So we're going to
see how that happens,
why that happens biophysically.
OK.
So let's come back to
our neuron in the dish.
Let me just explain a little
bit how you would actually
do this experiment.
So these electrodes are
little pieces of glass tubing.
So you take a fine glass
tube about a millimeter
across you heat it up in
the middle over a flame,
and you pull it apart when
it melts in the middle,
and it makes a very sharp point.
You break off the fine little
thread of glass that's left,
and you have a tube that narrows
down to a very sharp point,
but it's still a tube, and
you can literally just--
there are some cells, like in
the old days people studied
large neurons and in
snails where the cells are
a millimeter across, you
can take an electrode
and literally just by hand
poke it into the cell.
And then you fill that
electrode with a salt solution,
and then you put a wire in
the back of that electrode,
and you hook it up
to an amplifier.
Now we want to measure
the voltage in the cell.
Remember, voltage is
always voltage difference.
We're always measuring
the difference
between the voltage in one place
and the voltage somewhere else.
So this amplifier
has two inputs.
It's called a
differential amplifier,
and we're going to hook
the electrode that's
in the cell to
the plus terminal,
we're going to put
a wire in the bath,
hook it to the minus
terminal, and this amplifier
is measuring the difference
between the voltage
inside the cell and the
voltage outside the cell, OK?
Any questions about that?
So we're going to take the other
half of that piece of glass
that we pulled, fill
it with salt solution,
stick it in the cell, and
we're going to hook it up
to a current source.
Now our current source is
basically just a battery, OK?
But it's got some
fancy electronics
such that the current that flows
is equal to whatever value you
set, OK?
And of course,
remember, that voltage
is in units of volts and
current is charge per second.
Charge is coulombs, so
coulombs per second,
and that's equal to the unit
of current, which is amperes.
All right.
Now let's take a closer look
at our little spherical neuron,
our little neuron.
We've chopped all the
dendrites and axons off,
so it's just a little
sphere, and you can basically
model a neuron just like any
other cell as a spherical shell
of insulating material, OK?
In this case, a lipid bilayer.
This is a phospholipid bilayer.
Phospholipids are just little
fat molecules that have a polar
head on one side-- that means
they're soluble in water
on this side, and they
have a non-polar tail,
so they don't like to be
in contact with water,
and the two polar
tails go end to end--
sorry, the non-polar
tails go end to end,
the polar heads face
out into the water.
Does that makes sense?
And they are very closely
packed together so
that ions can't pass
through that membrane,
so it's insulating.
It's very thin, it's only
about 23 angstroms across, OK?
An angstrom is about the
size of a hydrogen atom.
They're very thin, OK?
OK, we have saline inside.
What is saline?
What is it in our model?
Remember on Tuesday what--
AUDIENCE: A wire.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It's a wire and we have saline
outside, which is also a wire.
So we have two wires separated
by an insulator, what is that?
That's a capacitor, because
it's two conductors separated
by an insulator, OK?
So an electrical component
that behaves like a capacitor--
like if you were to
build one of those,
you would take like a
piece of aluminum foil,
put a piece of paper on it, put
another piece of aluminum foil
next to it, and
attach wires to that,
and you would squeeze the
stack of aluminum foil paper
and aluminum foil together, and
that becomes a capacitor, OK?
And it has a symbol that
looks like this electrically.
So this is now our equivalent
circuit of this model neuron,
OK?
It's very simple.
It's a capacitor
with one wire here
that represents the inside of
the cell, another wire that
represents the
outside of the cell.
We have a current
source that connects
the outside of the cell
to the inside of the cell.
When we turn on
the current source,
it takes charges
from inside of here
and sticks them
through the electrode
and pumps them into the cell.
Does that makes sense?
This is our-- this is sort
of a simplified symbol
for a voltage-measuring device.
The voltage difference
between the inside of the cell
and the outside of the cell
is what we're measuring here,
and that difference is called
the membrane potential.
It's the voltage difference
between the inside
and the outside of the
membrane, all right?
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There's a narrow
resistance for [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: The resistance for--
MICHALE FEE: Yes,
but we're going
to do it one piece at a time.
So we're going to
start with a capacitor.
The resistor will
come in a few slides.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
So we've simplified our
neurons so that it's
just an insulating shell, OK?
No ion channels, no
current anywhere else.
If we want to inject current
into this simple model neuron,
we have to inject it through
this electrode here, OK?
So we're just going down
to the very simplest case,
because this is already
kind of interesting enough
to understand just by itself.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if the cell's
acting as a capacitor,
is their energy stored
in their myelin?
MICHALE FEE: The
energy is stored
in the electric field
that crosses the bilayer,
and I'll get to
that in a second.
Any other questions?
OK, great questions.
All right, so what happens
when we inject current
into our neuron?
As I said, the current
source is pulling charges
from the outside and pumping
them into the inside,
all right?
So what happens when goes on?
So what we're doing is we
are injecting current-- let's
say this is our capacitor.
There are charges, there
are ions on the inside
that are just up against the
inside of the cell membrane.
There are charges
on the outside, OK?
And when we inject a charge
from the outside to the inside--
let's put one of those
charges right here.
And we're going to push it
into this cell, when you inject
a charge, you get
an excessive charge
on the inside of the
cell membrane, OK?
And what does that do?
You now have more positive
charges inside than outside,
like-charges repel--
so it pushes one
of those charges
away from the outside
of the membrane.
Does that makes sense?
OK, that's kind of interesting.
We took a charge, we pushed
it in, and a charge comes out.
Right?
We have a current flowing.
We have charges coming
in and charges leaving.
We have a current flowing
through an insulator.
How is that possible?
It's a capacitive current, OK?
No charges are actually
passing through the insulator,
but it looks like you
have a current flowing.
That's called a
capacitive current.
And we represent that in
our diagram by a current
I sub C, capacitive current that
flows through the capacitor.
Pretty cool, right?
You have a current flowing
through an insulator.
That's what a capacitor is.
OK.
Now notice that you
have a charge imbalance.
You have three positive
charges here and only
one positive charge here.
So there is an excess of two
positive charges on the inside.
That's because we added a
positive charge to the inside
and took away a positive
charge from the outside,
so that leaves a charge
imbalance of 2, OK?
What do you get between positive
charge and negative charge
if you hold them
next to each other?
What is there in between?
AUDIENCE: It's attraction.
MICHALE FEE: Good,
it's attraction,
but what is it that
causes that attraction?
Remember yesterday, we talked
about a something on a charge
produces a force, what is it?
AUDIENCE: Electric field.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
So there's an electric
field between the positive--
the excess positive charges here
and the excess negative charges
here, OK?
That's an electric
field, all right?
And that electric
field stores energy.
How do you know there's
energy in this system, though?
What could you do to
demonstrate that there is
energy stored in that system?
Any ideas?
You have two plates, two
metal plates, let's say,
in the metal version of this.
Separated by an insulator.
What would happen if you
pulled away the insulator?
Those two things would do
that again, but louder--
boom.
What does that take
to make that sound?
Energy, OK?
So there's energy stored
in that electric field.
So there's a charge imbalance,
there's an electric field.
What does an electric field over
some distance correspond to?
AUDIENCE: A voltage difference.
MICHALE FEE: A voltage
difference, OK?
Now, there's a charge imbalance
and a voltage difference,
and they're proportional
to each other.
So there's a
proportionality constant
that's called the
capacitance, all right?
If you can put a lot of charge
and have a small voltage
difference, that's
a big capacitor.
Now you can get a big capacitor
just by having a big area.
You can see, you can have a lot
of charges with a small voltage
difference if you have big
plates on your capacitor, OK?
So the capacitance is actually
proportional to the area
of the plates,
and it's inversely
proportional to the
distance between them.
It's a very thin
membrane, which means
you can get a lot of
capacitance in a tiny area, OK?
That's pretty cool.
All right, any questions?
So charge is coulombs, and there
are 6 times 10 to the charges
in a coulomb, the
elemental charges, electron
or monovalent ion charges.
Voltage is in units of
volts, and the capacitance
is in units of farads.
Any questions?
All right.
So we have our relation between
voltage difference and charge
difference.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to calculate this
capacitive current.
How do you think
we would calculate
the capacitive current?
Well, the capacitive
current is just
the rate at which the charge
imbalance is changing, right?
Current is just charge
per unit of time.
OK?
So we're going to calculate the
capacitive current as the time
rate of change of the charge--
and I've dropped
the deltas here.
So capacitive current
is dQ/dt, all right?
And remember that Q is just
CV, so the capacitive current
is just C dV/dt, and
the Vm here represents
the membrane potential, OK?
So the capacitive current
through a membrane
is just the capacitance
times the time rate of change
of the membrane potential.
Any questions?
OK.
Pretty straightforward.
Now what we're
going to do now is
we're going to relate
the injected charge
to the-- sorry, the injected
current to the capacitor.
And what does Kirchhoff's
current law tell us?
It tells us that the amount of
current going into this wire
has to be equal to the amount
of current leaving that wire.
OK?
So we can write that
down as follows.
The difference in sign here is
because the electrode current
is defined as positive
inward, the capacitive current
is defined as positive outward.
OK?
So you can see that
we just calculated
the capacitive
current, it's C dV/dt,
so we can just
plug that in here,
and now we see this
very simple relation
between the injected
current and the voltage.
And again, the current
has unit of amperes,
which is coulombs per second.
OK, so we have that.
Now we have a
differential equation
that describes the relation
between current and voltage,
we can just integrate
it to get the solution.
So that membrane
potential will just
be some initial membrane
potential at time 0
plus 1 over C integral over
time of the injected current.
Just integrate both sides.
You get V here, you get
integral of I there,
and divide both sides
by C. Any questions?
It's either really
confusing or really obvious.
Yeah?
Everybody OK?
All right, good.
Now what is this?
What is the integral
of current over time?
AUDIENCE: It's
charge [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It's the amount of charge
you injected between time
0 and time t, right?
And what is the amount of charge
you inject-- if I tell you
that I injected an amount of
charge delta Q, how much did
I change the voltage?
Delta V is delta Q over
C, and that's exactly.
So the voltage is just
the starting voltage
plus delta voltage.
Does that makes sense?
This integral here is just--
that part is just
the amount of charge
you injected divided by C gives
you the change in the voltage.
So the voltage is just the
starting voltage plus delta V,
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
MICHALE FEE: Oh.
Because this equation
here just came from here.
That was our charge--
our relation between charge
balance and voltage difference.
Yeah?
If it's not clear, just
please ask, thank you.
OK.
There we go.
So what is the
interval constant?
It's just some constant
times time, right?
So our voltage is just
some initial voltage
plus the injected current
over C times time.
And so you can see where
this comes from, right?
When you turn the
current on, the voltage
just increases
linearly over time
with a slope that's given
by the current divided
by the capacitance.
OK?
All right, any questions?
You guys are being very quiet.
This is the point where
I start feeling nervous,
I went too fast.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You continually
draw the curve for a while--
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes, it does.
And it breaks at
about a volt or so.
Because the electric
field gets so strong,
it literally just
rips the atoms apart
in the molecules of
the lipid bilayer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Sorry,
I shouldn't say--
it doesn't rip the atoms apart,
it rips the molecules apart.
You need much higher
electric fields to do that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Oh.
Because we're integrating
from time 0 to time t.
We want to know the
voltage at time t, OK?
We're starting at 0, we're
integrating the current
from time 0 to time t,
which is where we're wanting
to know the voltage, right?
So you have to integrate
the current from 0 to t.
We can't use t in here.
t is the endpoint.
Yeah.
Does that makes sense?
Good question, thank you.
OK, everybody all right?
I'm going to stand here until
I hear one more question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Oh, here.
Because it's a
current of value I0.
Great question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So to maintain this
constant current [INAUDIBLE]
the amount of [INAUDIBLE]
you're pumping it and--
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
That's right.
This-- OK, I should have
maybe been more clear.
This current source has a
knob on it that I get to set.
I get to like--
there would be an
app now, and I'd
pull out my current
source app and I
type in 10 milliamps, boom.
And this thing-- because
there's a Bluetooth connection
to this thing, and it like sets
this thing to 10 milliamps,
and it just keeps pumping
10 milliamps until you tell
it to do something else, OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] make the
right direction instead of it
being constant current
state that usually--
MICHALE FEE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: --that would
create some weird kind of--
MICHALE FEE: Sure.
Yeah.
What would that be, actually?
If you put in a linear
ramp in current?
It would be a parabolic
voltage profile.
Yeah, very good.
That's exactly it.
This current profile that
you-- this voltage profile
is literally just the numerical
integral of this function.
So all you have to
do is look at this
and integrate it in
your head, and you can
see what the voltage does, OK?
Great.
That's exactly right.
So let's do another example.
Let's put in a current pulse.
So we start at zero current,
we step it up to I0,
we hold it there for tau,
then we turn the current off.
So let's start our
neuron right here.
What's going to happen?
What's your name?
I'm going to ask you
to do this problem.
What-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sammy.
MICHALE FEE: Sammy.
What's this voltage going to do?
AUDIENCE: So I'd say constant.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Because it's zero current.
Then what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: And it's
going to [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: And then the
[INAUDIBLE] go back to constant
at that point.
MICHALE FEE: Awesome.
That's it.
It's that simple.
OK?
Good.
All right.
Now somebody brought
up resistors.
Who brought up ion conductances?
Somebody mentioned that.
So that's the next thing
we're going to add.
This is sort of the zero
order model of a neuron.
It has the simplest view and
it's often not so bad, OK?
For short periods of time.
But neurons actually have
ion channels, all right?
Allow current to flow
through the membrane.
So we're going to start
today by analyzing
the case of the simplest
kind of ion channel
which is the kind of ion channel
you get when you take a needle
and you poke a hole
in the membrane, OK?
It's called the leak
or a hole, all right?
And we're going to analyze
what our neuron does
when you do that.
So what we're going to find
is that the ion channel--
a leak conductance, it can
be represented in our model
simply by a resistor, OK?
And we're going to have our
capacitive current, membrane
capacitive current, and a
membrane ionic current that's
due to ions flowing through ion
channels in the membrane, OK?
And that current will be--
we're going to call that
our leak resistance,
and that current will
be our leak current, OK?
So now, Kirchhoff's
current law tells us what?
That the leak current plus
the capacitive current
has to equal the injected
current, all right?
We know the capacitive
current is just C dV/dt,
so we just plug that
in, and now we have I
leak plus C dV/dt equals the
injected electrode current.
That is called membrane
ionic current, that
is called membrane
capacitive current,
and that is our
electrode current.
There's a sign convention
in neuroscience,
which is that membrane
ionic currents that
are outward from the
inside of the cell
to the outside of the cell
membrane are positive in sign.
Positive charges leaving the
cell have a positive sign.
It's just convention, it
could have been the other way.
But you have to choose
something, so that's what--
I think it was Hodgkin
and Huxley, actually,
who decided that.
Inward currents, positive
charges entering the cell
through the membrane going
this way from extracellular
to intracellular, are
defined as negative.
Electrode currents,
the other way.
Electrode current--
inward current is--
into the cell is positive.
OK, so we're going to poke
a hole in our membrane
and we're going to model that
ion channel using Ohm's law.
So the leak current is just
membrane potential divided
by resistance, leak resistance.
So what do we get if
we plug this into our--
I leak plus I capacitance?
Capacitive equals
injected current.
We get V membrane potential,
Vm over RL plus C dV/dt
equals injected current, OK?
We multiply both sides by
resistance, we get V plus RC--
that why it's
called an RC model--
dV/dt equals leak
resistance times
the injected current, all right?
Now that's looking a
little complicated,
but we're going to
simplify things now.
Tau-- I'm sorry, RC is
resistance times capacitance,
and it turns out, that
has units of time.
And so we're going
to call that tau--
got a little ahead of myself.
That's called tau,
we're going to make
that substitution in a minute.
But first we're going to
calculate the steady state
solution to that
little equation, OK?
So bear with me, hang
on, it's all going
to make sense in a minute.
Does anyone know how to
calculate the steady state
solution of a
differential equation?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Rebecca.
MICHALE FEE: Rebecca.
So you said the derivative--
so let's do that.
Set dV/dt equal to 0.
And what do you find?
Sorry, we flashed
the answer up there.
What do you get if you
said dV/dt equals 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
So you inject some
current, we're
going to hold the current
constant, let's say, OK?
We've put some current in
and we hold it constant.
The voltage will change,
and eventually things
will settle down and
the dV/dt will go to 0.
At that point, we
know the voltage.
It's just RL times Ie.
What is the voltage equals
resistance times current?
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Ohm's law.
MICHALE FEE: Ohm's law.
It's just when we inject
current, a bunch of stuff
happens, and when
the dust settles,
the voltage difference is
just the injected current
divided by the resistance.
Does that makes sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where is [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Well, right
now we just took a needle
and poked a hole in our cell.
So--
AUDIENCE: How big the hole is?
MICHALE FEE: Yep, exactly.
It's how big the hole is.
Now cells-- real cells
do have leak channels.
They're actually
ion channels that
leak kind of any
ion that's in there.
It's not very common.
And you'll see why in a minute.
Actually, that's not quite true.
There are ion channels that
look essentially like leaks,
and it turns out
that the ion channels
that many neurotransmitter
receptors like
glutamate and acetylcholine,
the ion channels actually
look like little leaks.
They pass multiple ions that
makes them look like leaks.
OK.
So in steady state, the membrane
potential goes to RL times Ie,
and we call that voltage
something special, V infinity,
because it's the voltage that
the system reaches at time
equals infinity, OK?
Any questions about that?
OK.
So we're going to just rewrite
this equation as Vm plus tau
dV/dt equals V infinity.
And that equation we're
going to see over and over
and over again in this class
in many different contexts, all
right?
It's a first order linear
differential equation
and it's very powerful, so I
want you to get used to it.
So what does this mean?
So let's rewrite this
equation a little bit.
Let's move this term
to the other side
and divide both sides by
tau, and here's what you get.
dV/dt equals minus
1 over tau V minus--
times V minus V infinity.
OK?
Now let's take a look at what
the derivative dV/dt looks
like as a function of voltage.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So why
couldn't we have said
we didn't mean to [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: V infinity
is defined as RL times Ie.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so
that's a [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: It's a definition.
Sorry, I should have put
like three lines there
to indicate that
it's the definition.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
Sorry, that's a very
important question.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Rishi.
MICHALE FEE: Rishi.
OK.
I'm going to make an
attempt to remember names.
So is everyone clear about that?
V infinity is defined
as the resistance
times this injected current.
So the injected current, when we
inject current into our neuron,
you're changing V infinity, OK?
You're controlling it.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
So let's look at how
the derivative changes
as a function of voltage,
it's very simple.
Bear with me.
All of this is
going to crystallize
in your mind in one beautiful
construct very shortly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
Resistance times capacitance
has units time, OK?
And so we call it tau.
Tau is just a constant, OK?
So hang on, bear with me.
The derivative is a
function of voltage.
And at V equals V infinity,
the derivative is 0, right?
That's the definition
of the infinity,
it's the voltage at which
the derivative is 0.
Yeah?
And the voltage is less than
V infinity, the derivative
is positive, right?
When the voltage is
below the infinity,
the derivative of
voltage is positive.
So what is the voltage doing?
It's approaching V infinity.
If the voltage is
above V infinity,
voltage greater than V infinity,
the derivative is negative.
So voltage does what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes, but it's--
AUDIENCE: Approaches--
MICHALE FEE: It
approaches V infinity.
So no matter where
voltage is, it's
always approaching V infinity.
If it's below V infinity,
the slope is positive,
and it approaches V infinity.
If it's above V infinity,
the slope is negative,
and it approaches V
infinity from above.
Pretty cool, right?
So V is always just
relaxing toward V infinity.
And how does it get there?
Does it go linearly?
Well, you can see
that the slope--
the rate at which
it approaches V
infinity is proportional to how
far away it is from V infinity.
And so it doesn't just go vroom,
boom, crash into V infinity,
it kind of slowly
approaches V infinity, OK?
Anybody know what that
function is called?
AUDIENCE: Exponential.
MICHALE FEE: It's an
exponential, good.
And it approaches with
a timescale of tau.
So if tau is small,
it approaches quickly.
If tau is long, it
approaches slow.
You can see that if tau is
big, the derivatives are small.
If tau is small, the derivatives
are bigger, all right?
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So a
tau usually is a--
MICHALE FEE: Sorry,
say it again?
AUDIENCE: --times
equals to tau--
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --is V
infinity plus 1 over e.
MICHALE FEE: At time tau, the--
AUDIENCE: Times V0.
MICHALE FEE: At time tau--
at time 0, the difference
between V infinity-- sorry, V
and V infinity is
V0 minus V infinity.
At time tau, that
initial difference
drops by about a third.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHALE FEE: About 1 over e,
which I think is 2.7-something,
OK?
So in 1 tau, this
voltage difference
falls by about a--
drops by about a third.
And in another tau, it
drops by another third,
it keeps going, OK?
All right.
So let's just write down
the general solution.
The general solution
for the case
where you have constant
current, that voltage difference
from the voltage at
time t to V infinity
is just equal to the initial
voltage difference times e
to the minus t over tau, OK?
So if t is equal to tau, then
this is e to the minus 1,
so the voltage difference will
be 1/3 of the original voltage
difference.
Is that clear?
OK.
So now let's see what this
looks like in our neuron.
We have our neuron, we
have a current pulse,
we have zero current,
we turn the current
on to I0 at this time, we
hold the current constant,
and we turn current off at
this time right here, OK?
So what does the voltage do?
Let's go step by step.
The first thing
is that voltage--
sorry-- the current controls
what in that equation?
The current controls V infinity.
So we can plot V
infinity immediately,
because V infinity is
just the resistance
times the injected current.
So what does V
infinity look like?
It's constant here, and then
what happens to V infinity?
AUDIENCE: Increases.
MICHALE FEE: It increases,
that's correct, but--
AUDIENCE: It'll
just be [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It will just be the
resistance times the current.
Resistance is a constant, so V
infinity will just go up here,
right?
Good.
It'll go up, and then it
stays constant at R times I.
And then at this
point, the current
goes back to 0, so V infinity
is resistance time 0,
so V infinity drops back to 0.
Does that makes sense?
That's V infinity, that's
not the voltage of the cell.
That's the steady state
voltage of the cell.
So now what does voltage
of the cell actually do?
So let's start our
voltage here at 0.
What happens?
Good.
What is it doing?
AUDIENCE: Approaching
from infinity.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It approaches.
So V at every point
is relaxing toward V
infinity exponentially, right?
And that looks like--
at some time constant, and that
looks like this, all right?
Now what happens here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Because V infinity
suddenly change to 0,
and so V relaxes toward
V infinity exponentially
with some time constant.
OK?
Any questions?
OK.
Now this-- that is our
RC model neuron, OK?
Resistance times
capacitance-- they
got a resistor and a
capacitor, but the solutions
are just exponential decays
toward some steady state
solution.
Now it turns out
that an RC system,
a first order linear system
acts like a filter, OK?
So remember, our neuron
that just has a capacitor
is an integrator, it
integrates over time.
When you add a
resistor, this thing--
it's kind of integrating
here, but then it
gets tired and stops
integrating, OK?
It relaxes to some steady state.
So this actually
looks like a filter.
It takes time to
respond to something.
So that system responds well to
things that are changing slowly
in time, and it responds
very weakly to things that
are changing rapidly in time.
So here's an example--
I'll put together
this demonstration.
In red is the injected current.
So if you have long pulses
of injected current,
the time constant of this
garners about 10 milliseconds--
I think this is probably a--
what is that, a 50 or
100-millisecond pulse?
80--
AUDIENCE: Nanofarads.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
You can see that in
blue is the voltage,
it relaxes toward V infinity.
And then the current goes
off, it relaxes back.
And you can see that the
voltage is responding very well
to the current injection.
But now let's make
really short pulses
that are much shorter than tau.
You can see that
the voltage starts
relaxing toward V infinity,
but it doesn't get very far,
and all of a sudden the
current's turned off
and it relaxes back.
And so you can plot the
peak voltage response
as a function of the
width of these pulses,
and you can see that for long
pulses, it responds very well,
but for short pulses--
really responds at all.
And that's called a
low pass filter, OK?
It responds well to
slowly-changing things,
but barely responds to
rapidly-changing things.
So it's passing low frequencies,
low pass filter, OK?
All right.
Any questions?
That was a lot of
stuff all at once.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious,
like on what order is
the capacitance for nanofarads?
MICHALE FEE: OK.
It's 10 nanofarads per--
1 microfarads per
square centimeter.
10 nanofarads per
square millimeter, OK?
We're going to get to
that in a second, that's
a great question.
We're going to get to what
the actual numbers look like
for real neurons, OK?
I think you had a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Sorry,
say it again?
AUDIENCE: Past [INAUDIBLE]?
Is that [INAUDIBLE]
reacts to [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: What happens
is it reacts to it,
but because it's
changing kind of linearly
at these short times,
it doesn't get very far.
If the current stays
on for a long time,
you can see it has exactly
the same profile here,
but it just has time
to reach V infinity.
Here, it doesn't have
time to reach V infinity,
it just gets a little bit away
from 0 and then it decays back.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there other sorts
of filters for non-responses
like [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: You can build
different kinds of filters
from circuits of neurons,
but neurons themselves
tend to be high pass filters.
You can-- sorry,
low pass filters.
You can make-- so you can put in
different kinds of ion channels
that change the
properties of neurons,
but sort of to first
order, you should think
of neurons as low pass filters.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
show the [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: I
wrote it like this--
you can write it as V equals V
infinity plus this other stuff,
but I wrote it like this because
what you should really be
seeing here is that the
voltage difference from--
time between the voltage and V
infinity decays exponentially.
So the distance you are
from V infinity decays
exponentially, OK?
It makes it more
obvious that you're
decaying toward V infinity, OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you were to arrange
like the physical properties
of the neuron itself,
you [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Not-- not really.
Not simply.
You can put in
certain ion channels
that could make a neuron less
responsive at low frequencies,
OK?
So you can make them kind of
responsive to some middle range
of frequencies
that won't respond
to very high
frequencies and they
won't respond much to
very low frequencies,
but for the most
part, again, just
you should-- at this point,
let's just think of them
as low pass filters.
We're going to start
adding fancy stuff
to our neuron that's going
to make it more complicated.
So don't get too
hung up on this.
All right, let me
just make this point.
This one right
here, V equals tau--
V plus tau dV/dt equals V
infinity appears everywhere,
it's ubiquitous in physics,
chemistry, biology, we'll
be using it in multiple
different contexts
in different parts of
the class, and in--
computation, OK?
And even slightly more
complicated versions of this,
like the Michaelis-Menten
equations in chemistry,
you can kind of understand
them in simple terms.
If you like have
a handle on this,
other slightly more
complicated things
become much more intuitive, OK?
All right, so try
to really make sure
that you understand
this equation
and how we derived it, OK?
OK, let's talk about
the origin of this--
the timescale of a neuron.
So the tau of a neuron--
of most neurons is about
100 milliseconds to--
sorry, 10 milliseconds
to 100 milliseconds,
kind of in that range.
And it comes from the values
of resistance and capacitance
of a neuron.
So a resistor-- the
resistance of a neuron--
range of 100 million ohms, OK?
And the capacitance is about
10 to the minus 10 ohms
or about 100 picofarads.
And you multiply those
two things together
and you get a time constant
of about 10 milliseconds, OK?
So what that means is if you
inject current into a neuron,
it takes about 10 to
100 milliseconds for it
to fully respond to
that step of current.
The voltage will
jump up and relax
to the new V infinity in about
10 to 100 milliseconds, OK?
So let's take a
little bit closer
look at the resistance-- what
this resistance in capacitance
looks like in a neuron.
So we've described the
relation between leak current
and voltage as current equals
voltage over resistance,
but rather than using resistance
to think about currents flowing
through a membrane, it's
much more useful, usually,
to think about something
called conductance,
and conductance is just
1 over resistance, OK?
So conductance, G-- and we use
the simple G for conductance--
it's equal to 1 over resistance.
So now we can write
Ohm's law as I
equals G times V. Resistance
has units of ohms, G--
conductance has units of
inverse ohms or siemens
is the SI unit for conductance.
So if we have
conductances, if we
have two-- let's say two ion
channels in the membrane,
they operate in parallel.
Current flows through
them separately, right?
They're not in series, like
it flows through one and then
flows through the other, right?
They are in parallel--
the current can flow
through both like
this up in parallel.
And we can write down the
current using Kirchhoff's law,
the total current
is just the sum
of the current through those two
separate conductances, right?
Now the total current is--
we can just expand this
in terms of the inductance
of each one of those.
So the total current is G1
times the voltage difference
plus G2 times the
voltage difference
for this conductance.
So the total current is just--
you factor out the V, the total
current is just G1 plus G2,
so we can write down the total
conductance as just G1 plus G2.
Does that makes sense?
So conductances in
parallel add together.
So if we have a piece
of membrane that's
got some ion channels
in it-- or holes,
and we add another piece of
membrane that kind of has
the same density
of ion channels,
you have twice the
holes, twice the current,
and twice the conductance.
So we can write the current
as conductance times membrane
potential, but we can
rewrite that conductance
as the area times that
conductance per unit area,
and that's called specific
membrane conductance--
in this case, it's a leak,
so we call it specific leak
conductance, and it has units
of conductance per area.
We multiply that by the area and
we get that total conductance.
Any questions about this?
No?
So you can see that
we can now plot
the current through the membrane
as a function of voltage.
This is called a
IV current plotted
as a function of voltage.
You can see that the
current is linear
as a function of voltage, right?
That's just Ohm's law.
And you can see that for a
low conductance, G is small,
so the slope is small.
For a high conductance,
you get a lot
of current for a little bit
of voltage, and so the--
deeper, OK?
So if you plot current versus
voltage, you get a curve,
and the slope of that curve is
just equal to the conductance,
all right?
OK.
Now let's look at capacitance.
The total current through these
two capacitors in parallel
is just the current through
one capacitor plus the current
through the other.
We can write the current through
each capacitor separately.
I total equals C1
dV/dt plus C2 dV/dt.
Factor out the dV/dt and you get
that the total current is just
C1 plus C2 dV/dt.
So the total capacitance is
the sum of the capacitances.
So if you have a
patch of membrane,
you measure the capacitance, if
you put another one next to it,
you'll get the sum of
those two capacitances.
So the capacitance
also scales with area.
So we can write down the
total membrane capacitance
as capacitance per unit area
times the area of the cell,
right?
And the area of a cell is
like the-- if it's a sphere,
it's 4 pi r squared
where is the radius, OK?
All right.
And here's the-- this
C sub m is called
this specific
membrane capacitance,
and it's 10 nanofarads per
square millimeter, all right?
OK, now, I want to show
you something really cool.
We have a cell that has
a membrane with some--
this cell has some time
constant-- remember,
10 milliseconds.
Now you might think,
oh, the capacitance
of the cell depends on
how big it is, right?
And so the time
constant will change
depending on how big the
cell is, you might think.
But let's actually
calculate the time
constant from this capacitance
and this conductance, OK?
So here we go.
Time constant C. R is just 1
over the conductance, right?
So the time constant
is capacitance
divided by conductance--
total capacitance
divided by total conductance.
But you can rewrite this
capacitance as capacitance
per unit area
times area, you can
rewrite that conductance
as conductance per unit
area times the area of the
cell, and the areas cancel.
And so the time constant
is just that capacitance
per unit area of the membrane
divided by the conductance
per unit area of the membrane.
And what that means is that
the time constant of a cell--
nothing to do with the cell.
The time constant is the
membrane time constant,
and it's a property
only of the membrane.
That's pretty cool, right?
Any questions about that?
Now in a more
complicated neuron where
you have a soma and
dendrites and axons,
different parts of the cell
can have different conductance
per unit area-- like
more ion channels
out here on the dendrite
and maybe fewer on the soma.
And so one part of a cell can
have a different membrane time
constant than some other
part of the cell, OK?
But again, it's a
property of the membrane.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in that case,
like different time constants,
do you have to like consider
flow between different areas?
MICHALE FEE: You sure do.
Absolutely.
That's one of the
interesting things about--
when cells have multiple--
they have different
properties, you
have current flowing
between them,
but you have to understand
this kind of basic stuff
before you even get anywhere
close to understanding a more
complicated neuron, right?
OK.
So we're going to add a
new component to our model.
It's a battery, and it's
going to solve one really
fatal problem with this model.
What's the problem
with this model?
Can anyone see--
I'm kind of showing
it right here.
What happens to this neuron
if I turn the current off?
It goes back to zero.
And in order to get the voltage
to go different from zero,
I have to inject current
through my current source.
Without me, the experimenter
with an electrode in it
injecting current, this neuron
literally just sits at zero
and stays there, all right?
It's actually a good model
of a dead neuron, OK?
So in order to change that, we
need to add a battery here, OK?
And that battery is going
to power this thing up,
so now it can change
its own voltage.
And then things start
getting really interesting.
So how can these
batteries allow a neuron
to change its own voltage?
Well, the way a neuron controls
its own voltage is it has ion
channels-- conductances--
that have little knobs
on them that the cell
can control called voltage.
So these conductances
are voltage-dependent,
and now the cell
connects these batteries
to its inside wire at different
times in different ways.
So let's say we want to
make an action potential.
So we have a battery that's
got a positive voltage,
we have a battery that's
got a negative voltage,
and we make an action potential
by connecting the back
to the inside of the cell by
turning on this conductance,
and then we're going
to connect the battery
with a negative
voltage to our cell,
and we're going to do
that one after the other.
So watch this.
We're going to connect
the positive battery
and the voltage
is going to go up;
we're going to turn off
the positive battery,
connect the negative battery,
the voltage goes down;
and then we're going to
turn off both batteries,
and the voltage
just relaxes, OK?
Cool, right?
So now the neuron can
control its own voltage.
But before we do that, we need
to put batteries in our neuron,
OK?
All right.
So anybody know what the-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
What does that [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good, we're
going to get to that.
That was-- exact next question.
What is it that makes
a battery in a neuron?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well I mean, like,
you have like something, right?
Even in like--
MICHALE FEE: Good.
AUDIENCE: --concentration
gradient--
MICHALE FEE: Good.
AUDIENCE: --so that
give us a [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Here.
You give the rest
of the lecture.
That's exactly right.
OK?
Well concentration gradients.
There's one more thing we need.
Concentration gradients
by themselves don't do it.
We need ion channels that are
permeable only to certain ions,
OK?
And that's what we're
going to do now.
So you need
concentration gradients
and ion-selective
permeability, OK?
So we're going to
go through that.
So let's take a beaker,
fill it with water,
have a membrane,
dividing it into two.
We're going to have an
electrode on one side,
we measure the voltage
difference-- sorry,
we have an electron
on both sides,
we hook it up to our
differential amplifier,
and measure the voltage
difference on the two sides,
OK?
Then we're going to put--
we're going to take a--
we're going to buy some
potassium chloride from sigma,
we're going to take
a spoonful of it
and dump it into this
side of the beaker.
Stir it up, and now you're going
to have lots of potassium ions
and chloride ions on this
side of the beaker, right?
Now we're going to
take a needle and poke
a hole in that membrane.
That becomes a leak,
a leak channel.
It's a non-specific--
a non-selective pore
that passes any iron, OK?
So what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
The ions are going to diffuse.
From where to where?
Somebody else.
AUDIENCE: To the
lower concentration.
MICHALE FEE: To the lower
concentration, good.
So some of those ions are going
to diffuse from here to here.
And we can plot the potassium--
let's focus on potassium now.
We're going to plot-- we
can plot the potassium
concentration on
this side over time
and on this side over time.
By the way, this
side of the beaker
is going to represent the
inside of the neuron, which
has lots of
potassium, and this is
going to represent the
outside of our neuron, which
has very little potassium, OK?
So if we plot that potassium
concentration on this side,
it's going to
increase over time.
It's going to take a long--
and the concentration
here will decrease
and eventually they'll meet
in the middle somewhere.
They'll become equal.
And that's going to take
a really long time, right?
Because it takes a
long time for this half
of this spoonful of
potassium chloride
to diffuse to the other side.
Yeah?
OK.
Now let's get a
different kind of needle,
a very special needle.
It's really small
and poke a hole
in the membrane that
is only big enough
to pass potassium ions
but not chloride ions.
So what's going to happen now?
Yeah?
Somebody-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Half of it
flows to the other side--
MICHALE FEE: Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So some potassium ions are going
to diffuse through this pore
and go to the other side.
And what's going to happen
is if we plot the potassium
concentration here, it
will decrease-- sorry--
over here it will
increase a little bit,
and the potassium
concentration on this side
will decrease a little bit,
but then it will stop changing,
and it will never
come to equilibrium.
It will also take a very short
time for that equilibrium
to happen, because
just a few potassium
ions need to go to the
other side before it stops.
So why does the concentration
stop changing here?
Well, it's because
the potassium current
from this side to this
side goes to zero,
and it goes to
zero very quickly.
So why is that?
Well, one hint to the
answer to that question
comes if we look at the voltage
difference between the two
sides.
So what you see is that the
voltage difference started
at 0, and when we poked
that hole, all of a sudden
there was a rapidly-developing
voltage difference
across the two sides, OK?
Why does that
voltage go negative?
Anybody?
What happened when these
positive charges started
diffusing from this
side to this side?
AUDIENCE: Didn't
you say it can bond
to the positive and
negative charge [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Basically this
is like a capacitor, right?
And some charges diffused
from here to here,
some positive charges
diffused from here to here,
that charges up this side, and
so the voltage is positive.
We put positive charge--
more positive charges here,
the voltage here goes up, OK?
So if the voltage here is
higher than the voltage here--
we're plotting V1 minus
V2, the voltage here
is lower than the
voltage here, and so this
is going negative, OK?
And that voltage difference,
that negative voltage here,
positive voltage here,
what does that do?
It repels, it makes--
the positive side
starts repelling which ions?
It's repelling positive ions.
So it keeps more potassium
ions from diffusing
through the hole.
Does that makes sense?
Blank stares.
Are we OK?
OK, good.
And it continues to drop until
it reaches a constant voltage,
and that's called the
equilibrium potential, OK?
The voltage changes until
it comes to equilibrium,
and that voltage difference
is called the equilibrium
potential.
And that voltage difference
is a battery, OK?
And I'm going to--
we're going to
explain a little bit--
I think it's in the next
lecture, the one that's
on tape that explains how
you actually can justify
representing that as a battery.
But right now, I'm
going to show you
how to calculate what that
voltage difference actually
is-- what's the size
of the battery, how
big is the battery, OK?
So you can see that when ions--
positive ions defuse to this
side, this voltage goes up,
you have a voltage gradient that
corresponds to a field pointing
in this direction.
And that electric field pushes
against the ions-- remember,
we talked about drift
in an electric field,
so when those ions are
trying to diffuse across,
that electric field is
literally dragging them back
to this side, right?
So we have a current flowing
this way from diffusion,
and we have a current
flowing that way from being
dragged in the electric field.
And so we can calculate that
voltage difference because
at equilibrium, the current
flowing this way from diffusion
has to equal the current
flowing that way from drift
in an electric field, OK?
So one way to
calculate this is we're
going to calculate the
current due to drift,
current due to
diffusion, add those up,
and that's equal to the
total, and at equilibrium,
that has to equal to 0, right?
So what I'm showing
you now is just
sort of the
framework for how you
would calculate this using this
drift and diffusion equation.
So we have Ohm's
law that tells us
how the voltage
difference produces
a current due to drift, and we
have Fick's law that tells us
how much current is
due to diffusion,
and you can set the sum of
those two things to equal zero,
all right?
And so this is the
way it would look.
I don't expect you to follow
anything on this slide
just except to see that it
can be done in this way, OK?
So you don't even have
to write this down, OK?
So the drift current
is proportion-- it's
some constant times voltage.
Fisk's law is some constant
times that concentration
gradient, remember that.
And we just set those two things
equal and solve for delta V,
and that's what you find.
What you find is the delta V
is just some constant times
the log of the difference
in concentrations
on the inside and outside, OK?
Now it turns out, there's a
way of calculating this that's
much simpler and
more elegant, and I'm
going to show you
that calculation, OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And so like
the concentrations inside
and outside, like at the
[INAUDIBLE] beginning of the--
MICHALE FEE: Yes,
at the beginning.
And the answer is that the
concentrations don't change
very much through this
process, so you can even
ignore that change, OK?
All right, everybody got this?
All right.
So here's how we're
going to calculate
an alternative
way of calculating
this voltage difference,
just really beautiful.
We're going to use the
Boltzmann equation.
The Boltzmann equation
tells the probability
of a particle
being in two states
as a function of the energy
difference between those two
states.
And one of those states is going
to correspond to a particle
being on the left side of the
beaker or inside of our cell,
and that particle being
outside of our cell
or on the other
side of the beaker.
And those two, left
side and right side,
have different energies, OK?
So our system has two
states, a high-energy state
and a low-energy state.
Boltzmann equation just
says the probability
of being in state 1 divided
by the probability of being
in state 2 is just e to the
minus energy difference divided
by kT.
k is the Boltzmann
constant, T is temperature--
this is the same kT
that we talked about
in the last lecture.
Now, you can see if the
temperature is very low,
all those particles are--
if the temperature is 0,
they're not being jostled,
they're just sitting
there quietly.
They can't move, they
can't get into state 1,
they just sit in state 2, OK?
So the probability of
being in state 1 divided
by the probability of
being in state 2 is 0, OK?
If kT is 0, this is
a very big number,
e to the minus big number is 0.
Now let's say that
we heat things up
a bit so that now kT gets big.
So the Katie actually gets
approximately the same size
as the energy difference
between our two states.
So now some of
those particles can
get jostled over into state 1.
And we can write down--
we can just calculate--
you can see now that the
probability of being in state 1
is--
divided by the probability
of being in state 2
is bigger than 0 now.
You can actually
just calculate it.
If the energy difference
is just twice kT, then
energy difference,
2kT divided by kT,
that ratio of probabilities
is just e to the minus 2, OK?
If the energy difference is
bigger, then you can see,
that probability
ratio is smaller.
The probability
of being a state 1
goes to 0 if you
increase that energy.
If you make that
energy difference very
small at temperature
kT, you'd see
that if the energy difference
is about the same as kT,
then the probability
of being at state 1
is equal to the
probability in state 2.
Those particles just
jostle back and forth
between the two states.
OK, so we're ready to do this.
Ratio of probabilities
is e to the minus energy
difference over KT.
What's the energy of a
particle here versus here?
Well, that's a charged
particle, the energy difference
is just given by the
voltage difference.
So energy is charged
times voltage where
Q is the charge of an ion.
The ratio of probabilities
is e to the--
Q times voltage
difference over kT.
Take the log of
both sides, solve
for the voltage difference,
V in minus V out
equals minus kT over Q times the
log of the probability ratio,
but the probability is
just this concentration.
And so we can write
this as delta V--
the voltage difference
is equal to kT
over Q, which is 25 millivolts,
times the log of the ratio
of potassium concentration
outside to potassium
concentration inside.
And that's exactly
the same equation
that we get if you do that much
more complicated derivation
based on Fick's law and
Ohm's law, balancing Fick's
law and Ohm's law, OK?
And this is equilibrium
potential here,
not electric field.
OK, so let's take a look
at potassium concentrations
in a real cell.
This is actually from
squid giant axon.
400 millimolar inside.
So 20 millimolar outside, so
there's a lot of potassium
inside of a cell, not
very much outside.
Plug those into our equation.
kT over Q is 25,000
millimolar-- temperature
at room temperature.
The log of that concentration
ratio is minus 3,
so ek is minus 75 millivolts.
That means if we start
with a lot of potassium
inside of our cell, open up a
potassium-selective channel,
what happens?
Potassium diffuses out
through that channel
and the voltage goes
to minus 75 millivolts.
How do you know it's negative?
Like, I always can't remember
whether this is concentration
inside or outside, outside
over inside, I don't know.
But the point is, you don't
actually have to know,
because you can just
look at it and see
the answer what sign it is.
If you have positive ions--
a high concentration of positive
ions inside, they diffuse out,
the voltage inside of the
cell when positive ions leave
is going to do what?
It's going to go down, so
that's why it's minus, OK?
So-- the battery
and in those video
modules that I
recorded for you, it's
going to explain how you
actually incorporate that
into a battery in
our circuit model.
And so we've done
all of these things,
we've looked at how membrane
capacitance and resistance
allows neurons to
integrate over time,
we've learned how to write down
the differential equations,
we're now able to just
look at a current input
and figure out the
voltage change,
and we now understand where
the batteries in a neuron
come from.